Okay, 8 weeks post-resection surgery were removal of the tumor and lymph nodes was complete.
By CEA numbers, August 7th showed high of 18.2, which is the highest, even in the worst time last June, it was only 6.1 in April.
So, is there any suggestion of why it's so high? Can this be temporarily because of post-surgery?
So really, the question is, can surgery cause tumor markers to go up?
And the answer is, yeah, it can. I can't point to any studies, but it's very common post-surgery.
It's very common during chemotherapy that tumor markers can go up.
So remember, those tumor markers are enzymes that can be released by tumors. They can be released by other cells too. They're not specific.
Only two tumors, nor are they specific only to a specific type of tumor. It's a few from like PSA for prostate.
So, yeah, there's times that they will spike. It's certainly very possible that it was due to the surgery.
You just wanted to keep an eye on it. If it was me, I would get blood work done on a monthly basis.
And again, I would have solely rely on that and make sure you're getting other blood work done too.
Also, I did take a signature circulated tumor DNA test. Their website suggests that circulated tumor DNA to original tumor mutations.
I understand its indication of existing traces of the type of cancer I was diagnosed with.
I know you said you didn't favor circulated tumor blood tests. Is this different? So yes, this, this they're looking for the different types of mutations, whether they think that if I'm understanding this correctly, I think they're looking at whether they think that the what they think is the metastasis is the time to the original tumor.
I think that's what they're looking for is it's the same as the original tumor mutations.
I have to look at the report to make sure that I'm understanding that completely.
What I've said that I'm not a big fan of circulating tumor tests, circulated tumor DNA test is a little bit different.
I may be wrong in how I understand it and I have to look at their paperwork and see what they're measuring.
But the reason why I'm not real big and just measuring circulated tumor cells to give an idea whether the person's cancer is better or worse.
Is because I don't think that the necessarily a shy level of circulated tumors cells means that a person's cancer is worse or and conversely, and then a low level of circulated tumors with people with metastasis but show no circulating tumor cells so they think that they're doing that their cancer is all better.
I think that you can equate that.
So when a person has high levels of circulated tumor cells, you know that they have cancer and you know that the cancer is giving off circulated tumor cells but it doesn't necessarily equate to a worsening condition.
No one does an absence or a reduced amount of circulated tumor cells suggests that the cancer is necessarily in regression.
So I just don't think that you could that there's enough data to equate that so that tells me that that that tells me where is the objective value of that of the measuring the amount of circulated tumor cells in circulation.
A circuit CT DNA test is a little bit different that's more like the IVG test and the more active that is that can give you a different idea so I'd have to look at the paperwork to really help answer that question.